I want to read a part
of a letter that you posted
on your Instagram account
in December, 2020, okay?
- Yeah.
- And you wrote...
So can you describe the weeks
and the months
and maybe even the years
that led up to you
posting that letter.
What were the factors
that helped you make
that monumental decision?
Goodness. Um, I mean,
definitely, uh,
obviously quite the journey.
I'd say leading up to it
and the months before,
what I really had was a moment
for myself, um,
where-- and this is obviously
quite a privileged thing to say,
but I wasn't working, um,
because of the current situation
we're in with the pandemic,
and I was up in Nova Scotia,
and I spent a lot of time
just by myself.
Um, and I think it really
allowed me sort of
separating from, you know,
that world, so to speak, uh,
for a moment, um,
to really get to
sit with myself and certain,
um, aspects
that I had never given myself
the opportunity to do,
and I think that was definitely
on purpose to a degree.
Even though I wasn't
necessarily aware of it,
just, you know, avoiding so much
in a way.
The busyness of life allowed
and has allowed most people
to not to look inward.
And so what you're sharing is
is that you had this time alone
in No-- were--
were you physically alone?
I was pretty alone
in Nova Scotia, yeah, like--
- Okay.
- I mean, seeing people,
of course, too, but really
purposefully was--
it was probably the first time
in my life
where I really felt okay
and comfortable alone.
It used to just be
incredibly difficult for me
to even just sort of sit
with myself.
Um, and this was a time
where that was possible
and really, uh, relax
and let my body relax.
I think I realized getting
to that space
and getting surrounded
by nature more...
- Yeah.
- It almost was like steps
into relaxation.
It was like I would notice
my body sort of go into that
space more and more.
And I think on some level,
it probably allowed me
to connect to my body
in a way that I--
I could really fully listen
to myself.
And I think for so long I...
didn't even have a concept
of what I was feeling, you know?